[Musique]
alors qu'elle prend en charge un patient
au choc hémorragique le véhicule d'une
équipe médicale du smur bloc cette rue
devant l'hôpital jean jaurès un
embouteillage secret certains
automobilistes s'impatientent et s'en
prennent aux urgentistes une dame a été
très agressif et elle portait un coup de
pied au niveau de la du thorax d'année
infirmiers qui est en train de prendre
en charge les patients avec est venu
avec une bombe lacrymogène et a commencé
à menacer un flot de personnes pour la
plupart mineurs se déversa l'intérieur
du palais omnisports de marseille
une dizaine d'agents de sécurité étaient
présents mais n'ont rien pu faire face à
l'importance de la foule qui a dégradé
des palissades des trottinettes et des
décorations la mairie de marseille a
décidé de porter plainte l'individu
arrive au niveau du conducteur
manifestement il veut un renseignement
mais soudain il assène aux policiers au
moins un coup de couteau sa collègue
assise à l'avant sort immédiatement
l'assaillant qu'on tourne alors le
véhicule et l'attaquent à son tour
pendant que deux de nos collègues
étaient assaillis était agressé les deux
autres qui eux ne l'étaient pas sont
sortis du véhicule ont fait usage de
leurs armes administratives et au bout
du compte nous aurons permis de
neutraliser cet individu qui a reçu deux
impacts on va pas s'apitoyer sur son
sort je vous dis tout de suite le
ministre de l'intérieur a confirmé
l'identité de l'assaillant il s'agit
d'un algérien de 37 ans arrivé en france
en 2016 avec un titre de séjour italien
il était régulièrement sur le territoire
national et la préfecture il donna
récipissé pour pouvoir étudier sa
demande il n'a à ma connaissance aucun
casier judiciaire en france et il n'a à
ma connaissance été fiché par aucun de
nos services je pense qu'on ne fait pas
le nécessaire en réalité en amont dire
qu'on continue au fil de l'eau comme
comme si à peu près on était dans une
situation normale proposition un peu
cocasse la proposition choc
moment c'est pour l'audition shops
propositions-choc cette proposition
assez surprenant si hier déjà copié sur
les autres c'est pas bien c'est gad
elmaleh qui m'a expliqué sa belle à un
copier sur les mauvais élèves du fond de
la classe et encore moins bien il a
déclaré qu'il voulait bloquer les
transferts d'argent vers les pays qui ne
rapatrie pas leurs ressortissants de ces
dunes solutions que j'ai proposées et
déjà nombreuses un certain nombre de
mois celle là est l'action directe sur
les visas remet je pense qu'il faut
forcer les pays à respecter
nationale à défaut d'union de la gauche
il aura réussi à créer la western union
de la gauche c'est le grand nettoyage
effectivement qui est en train d'avoir
lieu devant nos caméras
regardez voilà est on arrivé là on est
devant le le fameux mur vous le savez
qui est là le fameux mur qui a été qui a
été construit pour empêcher les migrants
et les pardons
ou delà des propos extrêmement polémique
qui ont vocation à buzz et à faire
réagir et qui parfois blesse au passage
d'ailleurs mais sur le fond dé lille vos
missions il vous a blessé comparez et
moore à de gaulle
ces forains
je suis pas sûr d'ailleurs que le
général de gaulle aurait forcément
apprécié ce que tu faisais moradi de
pétales quand il laisse entendre que les
fans français se serait donné aux
allemands puis aux américains oui ça m'a
blessé
on n'a plus rien on va prendre
[Musique]
une baleine de 15 tonnes s'est échoué ce
week-end dans le port de calais le
cétacé de 19 mètres s'est approchée trop
près des rochers n'a pas pu échapper au
retour violents des vagues trois corps
non identifiés ont été découverts au
népal dans la zone où trois jeunes
alpinistes français avaient disparu très
belle rencontre entre une franc comtoise
est une famille donc de ces félins sur
une route du département du doubs à côté
de pontarlier extrêmement surprenants et
inédit il y avait la maman et ses trois
petits